robert orlian and his partner in crime
john streep zipped through the murky
waters of the louisiana bayou on a
speedboat these men were dealers in the
illicit but their specialty was not any
kind of contraband you'd probably
recognize orlean and streep delton rare
orchids illegally poached from areas
where they're considered endangered and
sold to high-paying rare plant
collectors as any seller or collector
knows rarity is the hallmark of value
and what these two men would encounter
in the swamp that day was truly one of a
kind the problem for this pair of greedy
opportunists is that only one of them
would live to tell the tale and thanks
to the scp foundation the other wouldn't
remember it for long that's what happens
when you have a dangerous run-in with a
certain mean green swamp dwelling
creature that doesn't take kindly to
unwanted visitors and no we're not
talking about a crocodile orlean and
streep continued through the swamp
keeping their keen eyes out for the
flash of light blue that'd give away the
orchids they were seeking little did
they know from the murky darkness
between the reeds a pair of big yellow
eyes were watching them back
they were intruders in a stranger's land
threats just like the bad man they would
need to be dealt with accordingly or a
grim history would repeat itself the
boat came to a halt as the two poachers
finally saw one of the rare flowers they
were looking for arising out of the muck
orlean leaped from the boat and began
waiting towards his prize the flower
would fetch him and his partner a pretty
penny if they could get it back in good
condition the motions were so well
practiced for orlian so automatic that
he didn't even notice something was
moving through the waters towards him
gators and snakes were an occupational
hazard for people like orlian he kept a
revolver holster just below his shoulder
as a precaution but the thing about to
kill him was unlike anything he'd ever
faced before just as his careful fingers
curled around the orchid's stem orly and
heard streep screaming from the boat he
was frantically pointing at something
just beyond orlian emerging from the
reeds orlin turned and felt his jaw
falling open in horror at the sight of
it at first it seemed almost like a
water-logged corpse
thick matted black hair heavy with
grease and muddy bog water teeming with
parasitic swamp life her skin was green
and bumpy like that of a toad dripping
with viscous green sweat that seemed
like it could only be the byproduct of
rot but those eyes those big yellow
amphibian eyes they were alive as they
were inhuman this creature wasn't a
corpse it was something else entirely
her body cleared the water standing at
orleans height now and facing him eye to
eye she was naked her dignity preserved
by her long tangle of hair her body was
human shaped except for her freakishly
long thin limbs her belly appeared
visibly bloated or engorged like a woman
in the mid-stages of pregnancy orlean
had never smelled something so foul in
his entire life which was mostly spent
wading through swamps and bogs she
smelled like death itself
streep was screaming for orleans to
climb back into the boat but orlean knew
it was already too late he reached for
his holstered pistol but before he could
clear leather the creature let out a
horrific guttural hawking noise and
spewed a stream of black goo onto
orlion's face it was hot sticky and foul
tasting like a kind of tar rendered from
corpses it plastered his open mouth and
nose shut and began to suffocate him he
tried desperately to claw at his face
and tear the offending substance away
but all that succeeded in doing was
getting his fingers stuck while orly and
suffocated and streep screamed terrified
obscenities from the boat the creature
just watched and smiled through rotten
teeth it was nice to see them panic just
like the bad man who'd come before
they were in the wrong they deserved
this orlean soon realized that nothing
he could do would save himself he'd
spent his life in a dangerous profession
and been lucky until now but the reaper
catches up with everyone eventually the
last thing he saw as the world went
black was this creature
this
swamp woman wading towards him through
the water with a hungry look in her eye
she grabbed him on either side of his
face and just held him there what was
that sound was it fizzling like
something was burning or even melting
she just kept staring and smiling with
those awful rotten teeth robert orlian
went to sleep in her hands and never
woke up back on the boat a desperate
john streep was watching a scene that if
it wasn't for the later intervention of
the scp foundation would haunt him until
his dying day he watched his partner
undergo a process that was somewhere
between rotting and melting he withered
away in the swamp woman's hands
degrading into thick black sludge that
she drank through her thirsty skin as
much as it pained him to leave his
friend behind streep knew that there was
no saving him now
all he could possibly do was escape with
his own life he pulled the rip cord on
the boat's motor and tore his way back
to the nearest township the shape of the
nightmarish swamp woman shrinking in the
distance behind him when he ran into the
local police station half mad with grief
and fear screaming about the monster
that had killed his friend in the swamp
the police understandably detained him
for further questioning when his
criminal history as a poacher was
flagged up on the database it became
clear he probably wasn't leaving for a
while that's when a foundation agent
embedded in the department passed a memo
about the case's strangeness up the
chain of command and a covert mobile
task force was soon dispatched to the
swamp in order to locate and capture the
anomalous creature that streep had
claimed took his friend's life
after a few days of searching the swamp
woman was captured by the foundation and
redesignated as scp-811
before being delivered back to a nearby
containment site luckily for foundation
disinformation agents the cover story
was practically gift wrapped for them on
this one it had been a dispute between
two hardcore criminals and as the saying
goes there's no honor among thieves
streep had murdered orlean over a
pay-cut dispute and thrown him into the
swamp where his body was eaten by gators
a few falsified records and implanted
memories later and the foundation was
free to do what it pleased with scp-811
but the swamp woman would prove to be
full of surprises and contradictions
while designated as euclid the
containment procedures for the creature
were rather extensive for its own
benefit like a lot of creatures who'd
never existed in captivity before it had
very specific needs in terms of its
artificial habitat the foundation needed
to be on top of everything from the ph
levels of its soil acidity to the
optimal temperatures and humidity levels
of its containment chamber built to
resemble the creature's natural swamp
habitat the swamp woman is mostly
non-aggressive to foundation's staff but
certain precautions need to be taken in
order to ensure everyone's safety around
her while she's largely humanoid her
internal physiology vastly differs from
that of humans her veins and digestive
system are non-functional she consumes
her prey by melting it into black sludge
with the highly caustic secretions of
her skin before absorbing it back
through her pores the waste material
collects in her stomach which he then
expels voluntarily through an action
similar to vomiting this is often used
defensively or in hunting prey as the
unfortunate robert orlean found out as a
result people working in 811's
containment chamber need to do so in
pairs and wear heavily sealed hazmat
suits for obvious safety reasons the
creature also proved to be surprisingly
intelligent while not a genius by any
means it was no mere mindless animal the
swamp woman had an intellect and
communication skills on par with your
average feral child the one that had
been brought up and socialized in a
relatively normal home before being
turned loose and experiencing a decline
in its mental and social development her
words have a childlike construction to
them as though english isn't her native
language and she's still in the very
early stages of learning it she gave
herself a name i
and began to cooperate well with
foundation staff in exchange for having
her needs met since being brought into
containment she's made a number of
requests these include some requests
that have been denied by the foundation
such as the regular provision of bovine
prey for its chamber and a variety of
fish from its native environment to make
it feel more at home however there are
some requests that the foundation has
approved like a wooden hairbrush and a
d-class in a hazmat suit entering the
room daily in order to help wash her
hair often bogged down by the frequency
at which her skin produces thick caustic
oils in one particularly strange request
she asked for a turtle and a hazmat suit
to act as a companion in her containment
chamber as she reacted negatively to the
idea of having turtles as food sadly
this was one of the denied requests
scp-811 was also involved in a few
cross-tests with other anomalies leading
to curious results
after realizing just how dangerous
scp-811 secretions could be foundation
researchers naturally floated the idea
of using it on
scp-682 in its seemingly endless
termination experiments a sample of
682's flesh was successfully decayed by
the dangerous mucus so a larger quantity
collected over a number of months was
then sprayed all over the beast it
managed to reduce 682's body mass by 27
percent melting its way through the
covered flesh down to the bone however
at that point it was unable to decay
further and as cp 682 soon returned back
to its normal state who could have
possibly seen that coming right however
a much more interesting and enlightening
cross test occurred with scp-978
the desire camera if you haven't already
seen our video on the desired camera
it's pretty much exactly what the name
suggests a polaroid camera that reveals
the deepest desire of its subject and
the foundation decided to test it on a
large number of staff and anomalies one
of those being scp-811
when a photograph was taken of scp-811
just staring at the camera the resulting
photo depicted a human woman with the
same height build and facial features as
scp-811
braiding yellow ribbons into her hair
and wearing a blue sundress the
attending researchers felt this raised
an interesting question were they
looking at an aspiration towards
humanity from scp-811 or was this a
yearning to return to what had been
before there was only one way to find
out conduct an interview with the
creature itself when the interview began
the researchers pressed 811 on some of
her earliest memories one of the key
details she shared was regarding a
mysterious man whom she claimed came to
her before she'd look like she did now
back when her skin was soft and pink the
bad man he injected something into her
arm and whatever it was
it changed her mutated her took away her
precious humanity the first thing she
remembered feeling after that was an
all-consuming hunger and then melting
and devouring the one who changed her
destroying any possible answers as to
who he was or why he did it in the
process it was a story of victimization
and dehumanization so cruel and
upsetting that researcher watchtell an
assistant researcher attending the
interview actually threw up later
debriefing interviews revealed it was
because he had a daughter of roughly the
same age with long dark hair if scp-811
has any parents herself we may never
know such is the strange tragedy of
scp-811 whether you wish to call her by
her number a nickname like the swamp
woman or herself given name of i
will likely never know who she was
before as not even she knows now it is
an unsettling reminder that all of our
grasps on humanity are looser than you
think
sometimes all it takes is one chance
encounter to change who you are
completely now go check out scp-2845
alien god crash lands on earth the deer
and minecraft world destroyer scp-4335
a welt in the crucible for more
fascinating anomalous creatures